our next guest fled China during Ma's
Cultural Revolution and she believes
that America is threatened by the same
Marxist forces that propelled the
Communist takeover of her Homeland
joining us now is X van Fleet Survivor
of Miles Cultural Revolution and author
of Miles America uh so she what's your
warning tonight to the United
States the warning is a war has been
raged to America and that is the
cultural revolution
a cultural revolution that I experienced
in China That's destroyed China and it
is taking place right here in
America explain how the use of
propaganda starting in the schools and
then being promoted by government organs
and other government uh officials works
on the young minds especially yes that's
the indoctrination in school I grew up
in China you China and went through the
government School indoctrination and we
were taught the world is made of two
kind of people the oppressors and the
depressed and by now Americans are very
familiar with this concept the oppressed
are The Virtuous people and uh the
oppressor are the evil ones so there's
no thinking involved all you need to do
is decide who is who and if this is uh
the
you need to resist it you need to do
anything necessary to eradicate it
that's what happened during the cultural
revolution when the red guards turned
against the teachers turned against
their principles and turned against
their parents because they are uh
condemned as the enemy the oppressors
and this is same thing that we see on
the American streets right now the pro
ma Hamas Pro protesters and we see them
on campus and we see the same thing and
which is astonishing that now the people
are targeting Jewish students just
because they are now categorized as the
oppressors same toxic I want to also I I
want to I'm sorry to interrupt I also
want to ask you about how the government
the regime has to separate parents from
their children and turn uh child against
parent you the social credit system but
also that this idea of of tattling on
your neighbors and informing on your
neighbors I number in the Soviet Union
which I you know I studied in um many
years ago when it was still communist
and that was a big deal you know tell on
your neighbor and you get something for
it we saw that during the BLM riots when
some of the kids were telling on their
parents and they're they weren't
anti-racist enough that's exactly what
the indoctrination do and and then
turned everything into something like a
ideology based and if uh your parents
said something in and during the
cultural revolution against the party
you report your parents some parents end
up being executed here we're doing the
same thing and we uh encourag the
government even encouraged Biden even
encouraged people to report uh family
members that have extreme views and what
is Extreme view that's determined by the
government what is accept
acceptable what is not and when people
have hold the The View you don't like
they're enemies they're extremist and
that's what we see they this toxic
ideology ferment hatred and she the yeah
the the need to destroy religion and
traditions and history that's all
wrapped up in this right with monuments
with with books with you know they're
banning you know books in schools such
as Huck Fin and all these classic
American books but that has to go as
well correct in this type of Revolution
that is called the cultural revolution
you get rid of anything that is
traditional anything that is old and in
in China that's the Chinese civilization
to be replaced by mois and here the
radical left is trying to uh get rid of
the CH uh the American Funding
principles to replace with Marxist IDE
te ology simplified as
Dei uh G I could talk to you for hours
and I'm sure I'm going to have you on
the podcast great to see you thank you
so much